I have to talk about your skincare line.
First of all, I kind of wanted to bring this,
because I just wanted to show everybody
like what it looks like
when you are lucky enough to be the recipient
of this care package.
First of all, you get this amazing magazine, this 'zine,
if you will.
I mean, look at how beautiful this is.
And this line is so gorgeous.
I know, look at this.
Thank you.
It's stunning.
Thank you, it's been a labor of love.
So this is The Outset and we just launched like a minute ago
and it's been a project I've been working on for five years
and now it's here.
And it took a long time and you know,
this skincare is based on my own skincare.
You know, I had problem skin for a very, very long time.
And did, whatever you could, you know, took every,
like used every mask and prescription cream
and peel and whatever.
And I always felt like when I used things
that were very gentle and I would have this regimen
of like cleansing my skin, prepping my skin,
and moisturizing it
and just like putting the nutrients back in,
like my skin would be its happiest.
And then I would use all that other stuff.
And so this line is meant to be,
we call it like the white t-shirt of skincare.
You can like pair it with all, whatever else you're doing,
and it's not-
I love that, that's sexy.
Yeah, oh yeah, thanks.
You know, it's not gonna react with anything else
that you're using.
We've eliminated like 2700 harmful ingredients.
It's vegan, it's nut allergy free, it's gluten free,
it's clean skincare and it feels so good.
And it smells so good.
It's so moisturizing.
The whole story is all about moisture-
Hydration.
Moisture and hydration.
And you know, it's like, I didn't wanna just be making
skin care for myself.
So when we went out there and did our consumer research,
we found that actually the majority of people
are genuinely, like over 90% of people,
are happy with their skin,
they just wanna maintain the skin quality that they have.
And so, you know, it really is meant to used by
as many people as possible.
When did you have problem skin?
Because I swear, I mean I could like girl crush out on you
so hard, you're so sexy with the best skin.
Oh no, oh thank you, but oh, stop.
That's true, my God,
I'm literally up close and personal and I'm like,
and you just have the most beautiful skin.
I've been using The Outset secretly for a year.
(audience cheering)
Didn't you test it on Colin too?
Well when we were first coming up with the product lines,
he, yeah, he did, like the eye cream, he, that eye cream is,
because I never used eye cream, now I use eye cream,
but like-
You have an eye cream?
Yeah, I have an eye cream, this one.
I need an eye cream right now.
Yeah.
I really do.
Oh, an eye cream, I also, I love that we're sitting now,
that's fine, I also, you know, I've been told,
people have been telling me for years
I should be using an eye cream.
And then when I met, actually Colin is the first partner
I've ever had that used an eye cream.
I was like, oh, okay.
Oh, he has products and stuff?
He has like a few products, I guess.
I mean, he's not like overly,
it's not like I went in there and it looked like Sephora,
you know, but he's open to a product.
Yeah.
I like that.
I didn't have a lot of people in my, you know,
at the time we were doing all this,
like it was like FedExing over COVID like, you know,
we were doing all this testing ourselves.
Like my partner, co-founding partner, Kate Foster and I,
were, and our product developer,
and then the few people we had around,
it was like, her husband was using the eye cream,
Colin was using the eye cream.
You know, if anybody came over,
I was like, you want an eye cream?
You've got eyes, yeah.
And I'm looking at your eyes and I want this cream.
Yeah, it's a good eye cream.
We have had a lot of compliments with this eye cream.
Eye cream, it's an important thing.
I'm so excited that you have a skincare line,
because skincare to me, is my absolute weapon and arsenal.
It's my tools.
Definitely.
So I am so excited, I cannot wait to keep using these,
I trust you implicitly, I trust you, I trust them.
I appreciate that.
It's true.
(upbeat music)